this week's 48 hours investigates the
disappearance of a florida woman
after text from her cell phone raised
suspicions
early in the pandemic friends and family
of gretchen anthony were stunned after
receiving messages claiming
that she had a serious case of the
coronavirus and was at a local hospital
but when they tried to call her she
never responded
police went to her home for a wellness
check and found signs of a struggle
there
48 hours correspondent peter van sant
takes us inside
the search for gretchen anthony
on the morning of march 23 2020
friends and family of gretchen anthony
started receiving
disturbing texts gretchen anthony starts
to send text messages
stating that she has been diagnosed with
the coronavirus
chrisey mixon an assistant state's
attorney for palm beach county
says the texts described gretchen's
worsening symptoms
i'm really sick says one and in another
i am on a ventilator the family finds
the text messages that they're getting
from gretchen to be
worrisome alarming but kelly hanna says
her friend gretchen
was the picture of good health she
worked out at the gym
very hard she took her health very
seriously mixon says
friends and family became distraught
when they couldn't reach her
she never answered her phone it would go
to voicemail yes
so they asked police to do a check on
gretchen's home
where a neighbor told them she heard
something terrifying
i heard a really serious woman scream
like
just screaming like she was being
attacked
investigators became even more alarmed
when they couldn't reach her estranged
husband
fitness trainer david anthony neither
one can be found
police learned gretchen wasn't in the
hospital with kovid
so they searched her home for clues and
found signs of a struggle
and they noticed security cameras had
been removed from the walls
they asked gretchen's service provider
to pull the video from the cloud
the images showed a man lurking on
gretchen's patio
the morning the neighbor heard the
screams there comes a point
where this person that we see grab
gretchen
muffle her screams and take her into the
garage
this person looks up at the camera and
what do you see
we see david anthony looking up into
the camera oh boy peter pan sand joins
us now
peter who do police believe was sending
those text messages from
gretchen's phone well since gretchen was
missing and she wasn't making any calls
particularly to her daughter they
immediately looked toward the estranged
husband david anthony
who also couldn't be found and was
presumed to be on the run
the the home security camera footage
seems like a pretty big deal to me but
i'm not a lawyer how crucial was that to
the police
and their investigation absolutely
crucial it puts david anthony
in that house the day of her
of her death you see the two of them on
video together so it's absolutely
crucial
and in all my years at 48 hours i have
never had
so much police and security camera video
in an hour we take
viewers moment by moment through this
investigation you see
questioning of people and you see the
arrest and of course you see
video from the victim's home which is
something that's extremely rare
just the fact that peter that he was
using a covet as an excuse
it allegedly if it is the husband a lot
of thought goes into that in march 23rd
2020 that's when the epidemic was that's
when the shutdown was really
just beginning yes i was sick myself
with covid back then i was a bit
frightened by what was going on
and and the idea was i'm sending a text
we were all
confused by this mysterious disease i'm
going to be in this facility i won't be
able to see anyone for two weeks
police believe that gave david anthony
time
to make his his run he was headed for
costa rica
oh boy all right peter van sant thank
you very much and you can see peter's
report the covid cover-up searching for
gretchen anthony on 48 hours tomorrow
night at 10
9 central right here on cbs